hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical Texas sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the third section of the groundwork
of the metaphysics of morals a manual
cot engages it in a discussion that's
going to correlate something which is
very famous from one of his other works
the first critique the critique of Pure
Reason namely the thing in itself here
spoken in terms of the plural with the
nature of the free human being one of
the things that he's been talking about
is that even though we live in a
universe that appears to be in many
respects deterministic we are
nonetheless free in terms of our will
and our capacity to choose morality and
thereby to actually generate morality
and to understand its principle so how
how is this possible so count is going
to make this very important correlation
between two different types of what he
is calling Ruzicka
or or you know you might say fundamental
things and some in some of the cases of
the translation it's going to be
translated as causes these are to
include the things in themselves right
being in Veeck that are lying behind
appearances and we'll talk about that in
a moment
but those are also including the you
might call it the free aspect the
intelligible aspect of the human being
and that's where it gets very
interesting because we are as we're
doing this with Kaunas we're following
along we are engaged in thinking about
our own very nature now cut is going to
frame this at the beginning of this
discussion in terms of two different
worlds this is not a totally new concept
right Plato himself had something like
this we'll see other philosophers
actually trying to Wed cons and Plato
later on in any case we have a world of
sense the things that impinge upon us
for example you're watching this right
now through your
senses you're hearing you're seeing me
walking around pointing at this
chalkboard things are impinging upon
your faculties of sense and there's more
than just you taking in sense data of
course you're associating it together
into things that make some sort of sense
in a different term you're identifying
me as a human being you're seeing the
words there on the chalkboard there's
all sorts of work of what kant calls the
understanding going on as well there's
also the intelligible world the world of
the understanding this is not actually a
world that the understanding itself is
going to grasp as such so it's a bit of
a misnomer to call it the world with the
understanding but another way we can
talk about it is the intelligible world
right and the understanding is as
concepts of sort of spontaneity that
brings together these things the
understanding itself is not totally
outside of of sense but is it indeed
formed you know quite a bit in a way it
works by it by what's going on on this
side in two other words that we can use
for these are phenomenal and new middle
why do we use these sorts of words well
you know they come from Greek right
finalmente means the things that appear
in nomina is the things that are
intelligible the things that we can
understand yet not necessarily see with
our eyes although you know perhaps if we
want to be metaphorical we can see them
with the eyes of our mind or some other
thing along those lines so what lies on
the side of the phenomenal the
phenomenal world
so cut tells us that the appearances and
the knowledge that we have of these
appearances pertains to the world of
sense what are the appearances again my
walking around here you sitting in front
of whatever thing you're viewing this on
whether it be a phone or a laptop or a
television or who knows what yes these
these videos may be viewed upon in the
distant future some sort of hologram
something like that that would all be
within the world
of appearances what you're sitting on or
standing on that's all within the world
of appearances the sensations of your
body also within the realm of sense what
about the other side well Khan says that
behind the appearances behind the
phenomena we have to assume that there's
something else
and these themselves are not further
phenomena or appearances sort of like if
we're just peeling back onions or
something like that they are the things
in themselves to which the phenomena or
appearances belong and from which they
derive and we can't ever sense these we
can't have knowledge in any strict sense
of these but we can't in fact think of
them and now notice they can't I put in
this out doesn't talk about just the
thing in itself but he talks about
things in themselves in the plural so
there is a multiplicity there behind the
appearances we don't know exactly which
thing comes from what another thing that
we should point out is on this side we
can derive laws right we we have all
sorts of laws that pertain to the
natural things we call the inquiry into
that science and we can generate quite a
bit of that we can also and here's where
we start getting to the human being as
such we can come up with laws for how it
is that insofar as we are phenomenal
beings our interactions with the world
work our consciousness is spurred or as
Kant will say affected by the things of
the world so con khazana me says you
know when you think about how you know
yourself a human being not only can know
these things out there but can't know
the things in themselves a human being
can't even know him or herself in what
they are entirely that's an interesting
idea isn't it he says
a person cannot pretend to know what
that person is in himself or in herself
from the knowledge he has or she has by
internal sensation inner sense as well
as external sense nor can we know what
we are entirely by the appearances of
our nature the characteristics that we
have but you know tendencies our
interests our inclinations our desires
all that stuff is us but it's of the
phenomenal world even how our
consciousness is affected by say other
human beings or by other things within
the phenomenal world is on the side of
the phenomenal world and insofar as
we're considering ourselves in that way
we're not really free we are actually
subject to you know laws of nature they
may not be the same laws of nature like
gravity or things like that they may be
much more complex it could be you know
psychosocial laws right or however we
want to think about it but there's going
to be laws that govern that on the other
side considered insofar as we are you
know a cause literally a primordial
thing orsa right cut we'll talk about
our what's translated as ego our ich in
German the the real me behind the
appearances insofar as I am that I am
actually free and insofar as I am that I
am like the thing in itself there is a
something that's me behind the
appearances of the me that you're seeing
right now on the me that I conceptualize
when I think of that you know the guy
that I happen to be in my memories and
and you know what I'm going to eat for
dinner any of those sorts of things that
is where the locus of human freedom lies
and Khan says that we can look at
ourselves in both of these ways
at the same time we can look at
ourselves as an effect and thereby part
of this entire world of appearances or
we can look at ourselves as a cause and
insofar as we do so we are regarding
ourselves as beings that exist in this
world of the understanding beyond the
appearances